We are back
live. I'm kind of tired
today. Still a bunch of stuff to get
done though. I think we're going to
see I'm going to try to get at least an
initial version of this binding out.
Uh and then there are a few other things
I got to look into today as well. Let's
see if we can get this done first.
thing? Static
int. Uh, this should be pi object.
You turn null for this
thing. No, you can't.
definition. So you can't redefine this
thing. You can just do
this. That works.
One M1 worker. We're
good. Seg faults.
Super, I didn't see your previous
message if there was one. If all I see
is what's uh what's
This what we have. We have
uh prototype,
right? Bar arcs, keyword
fine. Is the signature wrong?
Do you ever heard of
any OS
dro
especially? No, you just use whatever.
There's no like you don't need an
operating
system for that.
Like if you want to run stuff that runs
on Windows, you use Windows. Otherwise,
you use whatever Linux you want.
Generally, Abuntu is the easiest out of
the box.
Well, I can just see where this is
seging, right? I forgot I can do that.
val seven
ah
really n doesn't
nums. Do I need to pass like empty arms
or something?
Maybe there's a reason for this. Let's
see. I didn't think there
was. Now you should be able to just call
this thing
weird. Something definitely is not
getting passed
correctly. Is it the signature?
thing. What did we get? Shared method.
Bad call flags.
API parsing arguments and building
values.
based. Yeah. I don't see how any well
way I don't see how there's any way
you're going to get Nate. Like there's
no way you're going to get native
support for PC games
working. Like the most you're going to
be able to do is run stuff. You're
probably just going to end up running
stuff via Proton, which is literally
built into Steam on Linux.
more like a college project.
Yeah, an operating system is not a
college project unless you're absolutely
sure you know what you're doing.
guess. I mean, heck, I started neural
MMO as an undergrad
project. Yeah. Like uh what are we like
eight years
Oh yeah, you learn
plenty. You're setting yourself up for
something very difficult, but yeah,
you'll learn a lot of
stuff. If that's your goal, then yeah,
go take on like the most challenging
things you possibly can. No reason not
to.
works? Do you need this
module? I might have messed up.
Hang on. What What's the signature on
like
these? Uh yeah, it's got this self thing
on
it, which is the module, I
guess. Okay, I messed that up. My
bad. I don't know if you can just have
keyword args either.
I think we'll keep the
uh signature. I have
team are you all like good low-level
systems devs?
So, like building an operating system is
technically like yeah, there there's an
operating systems course you can take at
Stanford that'll take you like 40 hours
a week and you kind of build an
operating system sort
of. I don't know. I'd probably have fun
with it at least. Lowle dev is great.
though it gets more fun the better you
know what you're
signature. What I did wrong here? My
object. You have to add it here,
Yay, we
run
fuel. Um, I didn't think that we had
subprocesses though. So, why is it
M
workers uh vec
multiprocessing. Uh so this can go to
native, can
native, we can actually put a break
point in here.
So yeah, you do get the state. This is
just a
pointer. Um this
is a thing that you technically have.
So now what we can
do is
like I can do like state equals selfc
state or
whatever.
Yeah. And
now I do have to unpack this
custom. So you will need Python API
shenanigans. Just grab the end code that
I use.
Yeah. So, you can't reuse this directly
because this is
So you want this here on a knit,
right? You do like a nit grid or
whatever. And
the the code for unpack
M. So I can see
API handle
state state
Yeah, that's pretty well
it. And then one is error. So we do like
this. Okay, so this gives you a state.
Let's see if this runs without blowing
up.
Yeah. So that runs without blowing up.
Cool. So now all we have to do is
um we just have to reformat some code
essentially.
code. Let me see what the current one
looks like.
is so I can pretty much just do this
code in the share, right?
And then all this has to do is randomly
pick an
end on reset
and whenever it's
done. That's not too
bad. We can do
that. We'll have to figure out what we
want to change with this for curriculum
learning, but this will be enough for me
to show Aaron. And
um this shouldn't take me very long.
Let's say I finish
this by
six. That gives me time to check.
There's one other thing I want to spend
like an hour on
maybe. And then hopefully we can
actually get a little time to
uh figure out what's wrong with our
machines and set up experiments and all
that jazz because there's still some
stuff we have to figure out. And days go
by too fast. It's like you need
unlimited dev hours in order to get
stuff
size. I guess you need this kind of in
both, don't
size. I think you just assert that max
size has to be greater than five.
This could honestly get pasted into the
C as
well. Well, it it will be C. So, it's
actually very easy to just move this
back and forth between this and the grid
file. It's not bad.
Uh now the thing that I was trying to
figure out is a really basic thing. I
think it's just like
five
plus percent max
size minus five. Is this it? Something
like
What's the uh the and float
whatever. There's like a common thing
people use for
this. Yeah, it's this
thing. You got to divide by the rand
max.
one? It gives you a difficulty.
Uh you do need an end to uh you need a
temporary
end. So let's just make
level. Create maze. Just rely
on height.
thing max size. Yeah, you do want to
init your thing
here.
Um, that's slightly annoying.
So you just do
n you set max
size and then you do indent
grid. And now we can create maze
level
and size difficulty I that's
fine and we do init
state on levels of
I max
size and we can do get state
something like this.
So that should the
levels And then I think the uh the rest
of the logic has to go into the end
itself,
right? Maybe this will take a little
longer than 40
bad. I think you need
um numb maps as well, right?
You want to
do set state and and then
state rand% num
maps. The x equals
reset, meaning that can't be breaking
anything.
call Why does this thing have an
extra? It doesn't making up.
And then you can ignore the other
bit. Okay. So I think we debug this and
like whatever I broke in here. I think
that's all the code. I don't think I
missed
anything. We will see. But I think that
that should be
about what we want.
bad, right? So, it needs numb maps and
it needs levels. No big deal.
levels unknown type state that needs to
be declared I
top incompatible type or set state set
state this wants
What I
do? This is not
this. Oh yeah, that's just
dot. And does there a dot max size on
this? There is,
right? No.
And
then how these became columns
but boom. All right.
this thing
run
or do we
seg I really should just build a debug
compile mode into this because then I
wouldn't even have to deal with it
seging I would just get the error trace.
It's still easy enough with the way this
is
though. Uh, I'm guessing I forgot
a Yeah, I'm guessing I forgot some arms
maps max
size. Yeah, I definitely just forgot
some
stuff. Okay, so shared N. It needs num
maps. This is invalid
max
size and
consistency. This needs to be mapped as
well. I
guess kind of doesn't
We will uh leave it for now and we'll
see because I think we'll need it in a
H
267. Yeah. So this is in set
state. It's fall from here.
Um, this got set correctly,
right? Hey,
Linky,
welcome. I got to figure out that
freaking cluster status like today. I've
been putting it off because of a lot of
I've been dealing with, but
also. Yes, Star
Puffer. Thanks for that
reminder. If you enjoy all this stuff
and want to help me out for free, just
start the repo. Huffer.ai. Try the repo.
Try to hit 2K really helps. That's all.
Oh, this doesn't get
set. Yeah, this doesn't get
set. Okay. Right. Right. Because I
didn't actually
unpack. I didn't assign this to the
end. I do end
state end levels equals state like this.
Yes. Cool. And we don't immediately
crash.
Do we actually get any infos back from
this
thing? I forget whether it just takes a
while or
not. No, I think there's something still
broken.
closer. Let's make sure we're actually
calling the logging function
first. Okay, so report interval. Yeah,
this should be getting
called. So, this is empty for some
reason.
We definitely log though, don't we? Oh,
we did we forget to increment
n? No, this is valid, right?
So, this is one path
here. We should just make an add log
function.
function somewhere after these
allocates. Yeah,
this void add
log n.
take this
is yeah something like
this
There should be a second one which is
running out of uh time. Right.
Well, now it should definitely be
logging. The fact that it isn't
is concerning.
I'm not like zeroing this somewhere
stupid,
right? No, this is fine. Okay, so we
just have to figure out where uh where
this is going wrong, I guess.
Just get a break point into this thing.
Maybe
set
state. Now, none of this stuff should
mess anything
up. None of this should mess anything up
at
all. You're not calling compute
observations actually in this, are
you? Oh, no. It gets called here.
gets called
here. Done as
false. This is done as
terminals. Reset does not clear
terminals, right? Because you need to
wait
correct, man. I don't know why this
isn't logging. This is very odd.
Okay. What are you
programming? This is a procedurally
generated maze environment uh for
Puffer. I've had this for a while. I'm
trying to update it to use the native
Python C API instead of Syon which will
make this thing way more useful for a
lot of the let's say a lot of the
reinforcement learning testing we do.
This is a really useful environment and
uh the Syon is kind of a limiting factor
right now. So this will make it a lot
easier once I get this in place.
Do we not increment the tick
ever?
Wait.
Oh, that should technically still work.
I don't know why it wouldn't work
there. It's better here,
but there should be one
agent. Oh, does agents also have to get
set? Hang on. Maybe I uh maybe that's
what I
missed. I bet you that's what I
missed. New to programming? You don't
know how people make real apps, for
loops and if statements, and just print
things to the terminal. Well, good news
for you. Uh, for loops and if statements
are bread and
butter,
like
there you might even be able to read
this. You kind of need to know what a
pointer
is,
but other than that, I'll show you
something cool.
I love getting new programmers excited
about being able to build full stuff
rather
easily. Okay, so this file here is 325
lines of actual code. In fact, it's
going to be even shorter in the new
version. In the new
Whatever. In the new version, it
is. Oh, huh. I guess I didn't update
this one yet, but whatever. It's like
less than 300 in the new version. So,
let me link you
this. This
is mostly for loops and if
statements. What does this implement?
massively multi-agent snake that runs in
your browser. Each of these snakes is
also happens to be controlled by a
neural network. A little bit more code
for that one, but yeah, you can build
some pretty cool
stuff with uh very simple
tools. So, point of this stream is I
kind of just hang around and stream all
my reinforcement learning dev. I'm a
researcher. My goal is to make
reinforcement learning a lot easier than
it is
now. And you can build upon stuff like
this.
culprit. I'm just going to hardcode it
here.
How do people make that though? How to
make
people make visual applications? Well, I
linked to the code, didn't
I? This doesn't seem too bad,
right? That's it. It's like 50 lines of
code with
Rayb. Ray is a very lightweight graphics
library.
Define some colors. Define a str. Set up
rendering
client. Couple of for loops in a net
statement. That's it.
Yeah, I highly highly suggest Rail. Um,
it has bindings for every language
pretty much. It's just a very simple
API. There's really not that much to
distract you or to like confuse you.
Just like keep things very simple and
you can do a
simple. Simple isn't bad. You can get a
lot done with simple.
applications? Uh so technically what I
do this will run as a desktop
application as is.
You compile it to web assembly using
mcript in which is like a JavaScript
wrapper that loads a very small amount
of well you end up with a JavaScript
of binding code around web assembly. Uh
you don't really need to deal with any
of it though. you can kind of just like
write your C and run it
wherever. This not every language can do
that, right? But languages that you can
compile to web assembly are very nice
because then you don't have to deal with
writing a bunch of JavaScript. I
wouldn't be able to write the code the
same way in JavaScript. I'd have to do
something more complicated because
JavaScript is too slow.
Seg vault.
Lovely. At least now we get something.
CUDA? Like for a video chat application,
can I make that in pure
Java?
Um, it kind of depends what you mean.
like low-level video processing is
absolutely not going to be written in
Java. Now if you mean can you write a a
front-end wrapper around like some
existing library that's probably in C++
actually it's probably f ofmpeg which is
in a mix of C and assembly uh and has
bindings for other languages then yeah
then you can do
that if you want to actually write like
if you want to do video encoding and
stuff probably
not also Java is gen generally really
not a fun
language. I do not suggest Java to
anybody ever for any
purposes. It also started in Java. It
was not fun.
comput
J won't seem
weird. Yeah, everyone does that. Job is
not fun.
range. This has got to be like my
fernal,
Really? Can I compile this thing with
address
sanitizer or is that going to like
compile Python with address sanitizer?
I think I can, right?
missing. I think I'm like missing some
uh is this
that. Okay, so that's slightly
obnoxious.
Yep. These before. This is like some
weird It's like some weirdo alignment
issue, isn't it?
Now I don't get the
message real invalid
pointer. I never call
This gets
calked. This ought to be
fine. And you return levels, which is
Yeah. Also fine.
How is this throwing an error in the
CUDA code? That doesn't make any sense
to
Is this some weirdo thing with the
Python
API? Oh, this can just literally be any
memory.
Yeah. So, F sanitize would fix the whole
thing.
Do you need it in link as
well? Maybe you need it in link as
well. Worth spending a few
minutes to see if we can um we can get
this to work because it would just make
debugging everything so much
easier. Like is genuinely not hard to
debug if you
have address sanitizer. Otherwise, it's
What?
Um. Oh,
dummy. What? Why did you do
this? This is the completely
wrong wrong spot, dummy.
enough.
Okay. Oops.
Why is it still giving me stupid
options?
I'm getting some like weird stuff
happening
in in
Hang on. Can I run like three other
ends?
Got to love how everything in C is easy.
Everything in Python is easy. And then
whenever the two meet, welcome to pain.
So, yeah, this works and somehow the
other one doesn't.
Well, I may as well get the pure C demo
working,
right? I doubt that tells me anything,
but maybe
This egg
false. Wait, this is compiled without
side. Seems
off. That's what I have in
here. There's my
main. Yeah. No.
With Oh, no. Create maze level
I don't even need that thing at
all. I doubt that's the actual problem.
That would be so weird.
side. So when I did this
here, create the
level. Grab a net state.
size agents.
You get the
base. Why does render never
happen? Oh, because you have to call
render once.
What's this demo supposed to do?
Is it supposed to
be actions of I? You know, it's supposed
to be moving.
happening. Is it getting reset every
time?
I only made one level though. So, how is
it
Was that just because I was controlling
it? No, it keep overflows.
513. I don't know what's wrong with this
stupid overlay. Like, I'm not even using
it. It must just be getting allocated to
the wrong size somehow.
We're not using it
fine. Now, do I dare take control of the
puffer?
Yeah, we probably need to fix some
things. But uh before I
see. Did we remember to fall in its
state after we make the
level
for I guess that's in binding, isn't it?
Yeah. No, we do call it state on
it. Okay.
Oh, hello YouTube folks.
This is currently getting a procedurally
generated maze and ported from Syon
bindings to
Cbindings so that we can use it as a
reinforcement learning benchmark for
some of the curriculum learning
algorithm dev that uh has been going on
in
Puffer. We're just having a
few binding troubles
So, and now it runs locally and see at
least. Do we actually get a trace?
I got to be like screwing up the memory
in this binding file somehow. You would
think, right?
Oh, wait. Is this I Hang on. Isn't this
numb
problem. No, that's seed.
Seed is
I really wish there were a better way to
get Python to not just eat all the
errors for no apparent reason.
I guess I could go check whether it
happens on a knit or on step.
Uh, how do I not get to there? Wait,
does it fail right
here? Uh, that just doesn't even make
sense.
ends. Is it as soon as you load
it? How would that make any sense?
Interesting. So if you import it, it
breaks before you even get to do
anything.
I don't see how you could possibly be
breaking stuff on
import. Um, yeah,
let's This is super
cursed. This is incredibly incredibly
cursed.
Apparently, we have 10 people watching
me debug horribly cursed Python
bindings. Welcome, you
masochists. Sadist
maybe. I'm going to try something that's
kind of out
there. There is like this niche bug I am
aware
of.
Um, there's this like really niche bug.
It would be super weird if this were the
issue. I don't even need to do all of
them. I just need to do step,
step? Oh, hang on. This returns a bull.
No, but that's the
agent. This is not supposed to return a
done. Then this step is going to be
undefined
binding.h. So, there's this really niche
bug as well. I don't know even know if
it's remotely related, but um there's
step to find I think it's like some
random reg x routine in C that can get
screwed
up.
Um, okay, that
runs or that compiles
import, but we still
fail. We fail later, but we still fail.
CUDA. I don't know how we get CUDA
errors from that.
Now, of course, we don't get a
reasonable error message. We still get
this peak
kill.
Why? Why do we get this? Why?
And here I was about to uh I thought
that we'd gotten
it. Maybe I should look around for more
of those. Do we have any other functions
with weird signatures?
This is void. This is supposed to be
void. It's just like render step and
close and stuff, isn't
void. Me rerun the C again. Make sure I
didn't break anything there.
I'm sure I did
Are there any other
um are there any other things that I'm
not
here? What about like
horizon? I don't see horizon getting set
anywhere.
It gets auto set from
this. Wait, does
it hang
set. We call this a nit
grid and calling it
state. We don't actually set the state
of this effort, do
Yeah, we don't ever call set state. But
then the first thing we should do is
call reset. It should do it.
which should set width, height,
horizon, numb agents, all
height width
height size is already set.
See
Also, why is this running in a
thread? Why do I get like a random
thread kill instead of getting a real
freaking stack price, you know?
now. Do I go back to the address
sanitizer?
line? You know what? Let's learn
something today. What's the reverse
command? Oh
Control R.
[Music]
Uh yeah, that's literally
it. I don't know why. Literally never
use
When I'm training in CPU
[Music]
mode, this is failing in get device
count. That doesn't make any sense at
all.
Right. Yeah, that makes absolutely no
sense.
Oh, and wait. This is with Puffer Pong
as well. So, you just straight up can't
run a dress sanitizer with
um with torch, I guess. Yeah, that
sucks.
anymore. I don't think it fails on like
any of the operations.
either. Yeah, back resets just fine,
right? The back
step. Yeah, I know. See, it gets through
back reset, but then it fails before
backst step somehow.
I'm not even doing anything weird memory
wise. I don't think I am. At
least you can numb maps
levels. I didn't mess up these two
things, right?
Yeah, you have num maps and num
ms, right? This gets num ms. This one
has num
maps. Maps, max size, size, max
size, num max.
My internet's
down. Hello. Are we
This might be reream switching servers
on
us. Yeah, internet's
fine. Okay, I think it's
back. I think we're
good. That was
weird. Get out of here, Twitchbot.
I build the
bots. This is a tough
one. This is definitely a tough one.
Let me make sure this is exactly how I
was doing it
right? And gets assigned max
size, numbum agents, vision,
speed, discretize. And I assign all
these things in the init grid function.
Now then you pull a
knit. Just make double
now.
Oh, that might be it right there.
I just pasted these at the
bottom. That could be
it. That could totally be on me.
bizarrely
slow. Do
this. There we
are. My
bad. Uninitialized variable.
I'm trying to think if there's anything
I could have done to prevent that.
in? I'm sure that this gets used in a
memory allocation somewhere. So, I
thought I was allocating the memory, but
I wasn't because it was
silly. Let's see whether uh this does
anything now.
Believe we had some baselines for
comparison at some point earlier today,
didn't we?
Let me find the graph that I had from
earlier
today. I think it was this. I think we
got like 80%
in 100 mil steps
before. So, we're not doing that right
now. I have to see if it's apples to
apples, though.
Also, while we're
here, we may as well
um we should have a neural MMO
experiment still
running. Yeah. Okay. Something
definitely wrong. These tests are not
since we added the advantage filtering
stuff has not been working fully
correctly. This is still training but
it's not training as quickly as
before. But this will pass for
um interface. So like we can actually
test the interface at
least and then I will have to deal with
the rest of this. I think we shipped
this for
now. Uh let me double check really
n maps. No, I think this is correct. I
think these were the same settings we
were using.
Not like zeroing out the reward or
anything. Dumb,
right? Red
counts. No, that's fine.
Okay. Well, we will leave this be.
Actually, this is not bad. I'm seeing
now that we're only at 100 mil. This is
6. That's lower than before, but it's
not like ridiculously low.
And it's possible we played with some
other stuff in the
meantime. All
right,
Cool. So,
um, let me switch gears to something
real
quick. Do we have Isaac on here?
Now, we don't have any of this stuff set
up. That's
unfortunate. Let me go get all that. I
have to
uh we shipped some code a while ago on
robotic
stuff and I just have to make sure
uh I just have to make sure
did. So, some folks are having some
trouble loading
it. No, Isaac thing in
here. I think I just put it in the repo,
Let me find the link and then we will go
do that.
It's not covered chat. It was nice and
quiet tonight.
Don't want to redo the whole container.
I just want to get this one thing
running.
What? Let me also find the model that we
trained.
So, we're going to see if we can load
that in.
We will
um grab the
policy. We having connectivity problems
again. Stream shows it's fine, but X now
shows it's
offline. So this is a uh animation
generation
model. It goes through a physics sim. It
uses reinforcement learning to correct
motions by like running the physics and
making sure that it makes sense.
Uh all I got to do on this just a real
quick job. I have to uh make sure that
this thing actually runs the way uh we
expect it to because some folks using
this were having some trouble.
Right. Have to get Isaac
gem. It's
annoying. It is quite easy to get at
least.
sim. Is this a pip install? Is this in
the dependencies here?
Oh, wait. This is the wrong one, isn't
it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's not warp.
It's
whatever. What did he name this?
This this is definitely killing editing
Yes.
Yeah, this is set up with Pixie
annoyingly.
There's like so many domain specific
applications that we could make work.
It's just there's like so much sludge to
wade
through. This is after cleaning
everything up.
The unit code
um loading is kind of funny
though. Oh, did I miss a
message? I don't know when that was
from. Is that Did I miss that from a
long time ago? No. Four minutes. All
right. I just started understanding RL
implementation of breakout
DQN on your ocean breakout.
I want to know if it does a fire
reset on it. Yeah, it'll auto
reset.
So, I forget what fire reset. I think
that's the
uh is that when it like it'll fire
automatically? If so,
yes. It can't just sit around and like
keep the ball on the paddle. Also, the
environment will auto reset. You don't
need to reset it. You will get the done
signal back from the environment, but
you will not need to reset
it if that
helps. I believe that's on latest
version as well. Uh the 2.0
version, it may or may not fire the ball
on its own. I forget whether we have
that on 2.0. Definitely the dev branch.
Uh it fires on its
own. Either way, it'll auto
reset. Yeah, I just I missed that for a
few minutes. My bad. I had windows
covering the chat
up. I have like way too many random
projects floating around in my head at
the moment. need to like finish this
stuff up, fix the cluster, and uh set
aside some good dev time to fix all the
things I've been working on lately.
Jim? Oh, inside VS Code. We don't need
that.
I thought I had these already actually.
Don't I do I not have these Ready?
Yeah. So this is supposed to be the
specific model I guess right
found I need to go get the data files,
don't I?
works. That's like a ridiculously hard
motion.
What the hell happened to my
button?
Okay. Well, whatever the hell that
was didn't freaking work.
easier. Uh, this looks to be a different
format
Okay. Well, I got this up and running.
At least I need to figure out the uh the
data. Kim will tell me what the data
format was for this. No big deal. Um
what time is it? 7:43.
Yeah, I think we've got this is enough
that we'll be able to quickly sort this
out tomorrow.
send a quick message on that and then we
will uh I'll take two and then we will
do some other
right, that's set. There's the restroom
real quick. And then I
think we do also have to fix the damn
cluster. So that might be more of a
tomorrow morning kind of a thing.
We will
see. There's definitely still some stuff
I need to finish
tonight. Tomorrow might be a lot of
cluster depth.
Um, I'll be right back and then we'll
see what we're going to do. One second.
Well, of course I checked my texts and I
have more bug messages for stuff I am
supporting. So, I'm going to go deal
with that one. This one should actually
be quick.
And then hopefully I'll at least have
like an hour to
do a little bit of follow-up stuff on
the main
repo. We still have some things to fix
there as
well. Get the
Slack. Find the repo.
See if they've given me repro
random loop of random actions without
sampling. It seems that there is no fire
reset
as the OBS remains the same. Yeah,
that's possible. Um I think on the main
2.0 I'm pretty sure that we didn't it
there yet?
Uh without sampling fire equals
one. If you sample random actions, it
should
fire. It's just in there as uh as one of
the actions it can
take. Let me find it for you.
Okay. So, no op is zero, fire is one,
left is two, and right is
three in the uh the
Yeah. And you're getting ops remain the
same.
Check if it I rejected when the sampler
gives
one. Oh, okay. I see. Yeah. So, we
changed this.
Um, in
2.0 it works, I believe, like breakout
does without that wrapper. And then we
realized that what can happen is if you
get really bad hyperparameters,
uh, you can never fire the ball. So you
never get any score and it breaks
logging. So I just made it auto fire
after that because it really doesn't
change anything with the learning
problem if you think about it. And it
just like prevents that annoying edge
case from happening.
It would be the type of thing where
you'd run like a sweep of 50 experiments
and then one would like hang with no
data because, you know, you need at
least some data to log and it's just
sitting there not firing the
ball. But that doesn't happen with good
hyperparameters. That only happens if
you're like sweeping arbitrary
hyperparameters and your model's really
bad.
Also, the whole code for Breakout
is I guess it's kind of long. We did
some like stuff on the physics in here
like to improve cuz the original Atari
has a bunch of physics bugs. So, we
tried to improve on that a little bit.
So, there's some extra physics in here,
but 2.0 is current. Yeah, 2.0 0 is the
current version that same people use
unless you're trying to do like bleeding
ed edge dead stuff on the version of
puffer lib that I'm allowed to break
without notice. So
uh 2.0 know is now
like January, February, March, April is
four months behind
uh is four months behind dev and we have
a lot of new cool new stuff in dev. But
it's also a mess and like I need to
clean up a whole bunch of stuff before
everything is good and stable there cuz
our release cycles are pretty long. You
know, we we usually do like six month
release cycle or
whatever and then there's a lot of stuff
in those
releases. 2.0 is also the default
branch. So that's what you'll get if you
just know clone the
basic clone it and like don't branch
the I need this
thing public, right?
right. Whatever. Can't test this until
they give me access to data files. So,
we get a little bit of a repeat for now.
Um, so the main
thing there are a few things I want to
do, but really the biggest most
important thing at the moment
is figuring
out the perf. We're
seeing Yeah, this episode return kind of
just gets screwed up.
It's not like anything is horrible early
on
here. There's a big entropy crash here,
but it's already dead by
then. This Okay, value loss spike could
explain
something. I guess I want to just run
some
basic basic experiments real quick.
But with this, it could definitely be
the
works. 20 million steps. Yep, this still
totally works.
Oh, break up's
broken. How'd that happen?
Um, cool. Cuz I had this working earlier
today.
Yeah, this is off. So, this shouldn't be
affecting
Entry
processing. That shouldn't be it.
Oh, you don't need to zero this. This is
bad. Yeah, don't zero this.
Okay. Yeah. So in this case pull
is these ones are all Yeah. Okay.
4096 on episode lengths. Is supposed to
be
rows. So there's got to be an assert
there, I think. But this should be
correct. This gives you precisely
Like you're missing one step at the end
of this trajectory.
use this
for that's just
logs f length f indices
Yeah, it
does. So, this
trains. So, I'm probably batching
something wrong, right? There's probably
like some edge
case. Yeah, cuz this matches like the
previous
solves. Oh, I didn't see that. I got
Insta added to that.
Let me go do that real quick.
That is a 1 gigabyte
CSV. That is
impressive. One gigabyte CSV.
32. There's no way this is that silly of
an
error. Is this
actually I literally told them about
this one, didn't I?
Where's the
end? This
32. It's not even made for size that
small,
mate. That's not even made for something
that small. That's crazy.
I guess this one's not got to be like
this or something, right?
That looks like it's going to take
forever to
run. Yep, that's actually going to take
forever to run. That's crazy. It's like
manually loading that file a billion
times. We're going to do like
slow. I think it's like plotting or some
crap though. They haven't tried to
optimize this at all.
So, I'll let them screw with that for a
while. I unblock them at
least. Back to the real work
So, we know for sure it's uh some sort
of
weird issue, right? Cuz this one doesn't
work. It works with one and not with
two.
Yeah. So, see it starts working and then
it
interesting. Do we just have to zero all
the buffers?
still crashing. So, it's not zeroing
buffers. Got to be like writing the
index wrong,
right? You would think
so. I mean, this is a fiddly little bit
of logic.
Yeah, this is like simple simple J.
There's nothing wrong here.
Yeah. Okay. So, this is this looks good
to me.
reasonable. I don't think there's any
trouble you can even get into after you
um you get to the sampling stage, right?
You kind of already have all your data
by
then, I guess. Like
technically plus equals Z. You add it
though. Yeah. Plus plus equals. This is
fine.
right? No, because these indices come
from here. These are unrelated.
I thought that this was working before
as well. It doesn't like suddenly work
if I do this right.
before. Definitely had this working
before.
And it still works with one
end as the kicker. So I definitely just
screwed up some of this indexing and I'm
not seeing
it. 834. I'm going to give it like a
good 20 minutes right now. See if we can
find it. And if not, it's going to be
for the morning.
See how I call
this state of value action.
weird. A lot of weird bugs today
though. A lot of weird bugs
today. It's not a masking bug. We don't
use masking for this.
It's got to be either in store or the
way that we're using those indices, I
would
Something is wrong
there. Something is in fact wrong
there. Why the f length's
55? Doesn't make sense, right?
somehow. If that's going to be the
case, that's going to be pretty gross.
Not multiprocessing
save. Cool.
Yeah, that's really
bad. Okay. Well,
uh, we found
it. I think we'll even do this. Let's
just make sure it works with this as
well. We'll push
this. We'll run neural MMO. We'll see if
we can actually get the to train
now. I'm pretty damn sure this is a
problem,
though. So, what happened
is since we're collecting trajectory
segments, we're kind of assuming they're
a fixed length.
Now, I mean, I have here like I have
ways around this and ways to fix this
stuff, but it's going to require a
little bit of care.
At least we'll be able to test neural
MMO tonight. That's the thing. I didn't
want to waste a night of having like no
runs
overnight. This even looks a little
better than the previous. This is
good. Okay. Advanced filtering. Good.
23% time on the ends without the uh
multipprocessing, but it'll be enough
for us to run an experiment.
today. Definitely need to up the back
prop horizon as well.
Whatever. Then I commit this file,
dummy.
All right, we found the
bug. Very
good. I'm going to do a couple more
things. I think we'll see. But,
um, for folks watching, since we do have
a fair few folks on at the moment, I
stream all my dev. This is mostly it's
semi-educational but also just like
watch RL research happen live. I guess
it's a good mix of science and
engineering. Um, if you want to help me
out for free, start the GitHub. It's all
open source.
Huffer.ai. It's all right here. Start
the repo. We're trying to hit 2K. If you
want to get involved with dev, join the
Discord.
Many of our best contributors now came
in with zero RL experience. Frankly,
just having like a decent programming
background and being able to write very
simple low-level code without making a
mess is probably more valuable coming
in. And if you want more RL content, you
can just follow me on X as well, where I
post pretty much exclusively RL content
there,
too. Let's see what we finish up with
tonight. Good day overall.
Good day
thing. Oh, did I make score equal to
mincom prof? I think I think I did do
that,
right? Yeah. So, I made everything have
a score so that it would be easier.
goes. Um I guess I can talk through
since I usually end at like nine. I'll
uh I'll talk through a few things with
the buffer design. So basically what
happened here
oops. Here's what happened with the
buffer,
right?
Before you were getting batches of
experience. So, you have like this big
bank of
environments, right? Ms.
All right. Then what would happen is
like you would get a batch of experience
like
this and then you would get like a batch
of experience like
this. Uh but they aren't necessarily
going to all come alternating, right? So
you could do something like
this. You know, they come in whatever
order they happen to be ready in.
So before I was essentially taking all
this data as it came in and putting it
into a big flat buffer, but I was also
tracking
indices. So what would happen is if uh
if you got more data from one than the
other, you know, maybe this would be
like one, two, three,
four, and then you had like one, two,
three, four, whatever. You could
actually reassemble them into the order
so that like one and four are
contiguous, two and three are
contiguous, and everything is happy.
The problem is uh I don't want to be
storing data flat like this. Now with
the new experience buffer
design, it makes it very hard to do
advantage
filtering. What I have now is we still
have the same
M. Okay, but the experience buffer is no
longer flat. It looks like
this. So you have a certain number of
rows
And then this is the trajectory segment
length. And what happens now is like
let's say you get your experience
buffers. All right. So this is your M's
again and they come in out of
order. Let's draw a few more of them
this time.
What happens is that you fill in one,
two. So you fill in this with here. Then
you fill in this from here. But you've
actually filled
in you filled in all of
this. And what happens is as soon as you
get to the end of one of
these, as soon as you get to the end of
one of these, um, it just says, "Okay,
we're
done." And you say, "Well, what about
all this data?" Well, it doesn't account
for it. So, now you have partial
trajectories in
here, and that can really screw stuff
It's a little tricky the way
vectorization is written at the
moment. The easiest fix I could come up
with for this would be to do a round
robin type of a
thing, right? And I could just instead
of changing the experience buffer, I
could change the
vectorzation so that it just does the
roundroin. So you know, then the data
comes in like this and then like this
and then like this and like
this. And with all of our amps, that'll
still be nice and fast.
bad. I probably could even come up with
smart way to do
it because like so slower MS typically
have a bunch of processes so it's not
just like two big buffers going back and
forth it's like 20 little
buffers. I could probably even do it so
that instead of it having to be
roundroin it could be just
like you're guaranteed that you get one
step from each end before it starts
repeating. You
know, I could do
that.
Okay, that's not a bad fix. That's not a
bad fix at
all. I don't have time to implement that
tonight, but that's what we'll do in the
We're not going to see mincom prof,
right?
Score. Yeah, score is going to be flat
for quite a while. I don't expect that
to be magically better. It takes a long
time to get any score in neural mo. It's
a very hard end. You see the return go
up. So, you're getting rewards, but
you're not getting scoring points.
Points are way harder to get than
reward.
Only other thing I can do to to think to
do is look at the network, but I've only
got a few minutes. Um, I try to keep
my, you know, one of the things I've
noticed with all this the work that I do
on this, I mean, I pretty much just
work, eat, sleep,
exercise.
Um, it's pretty hard to keep that
schedule if you get out of sync. at
least it is for me. But if I keep sleep
on schedule, get good sleep, get a good
diet and everything, get my exercise in
and everything's kind of well
regimented, then it's pretty easy to
keep working the longer
hours. But yeah, tomorrow we will fix
this buffer. Uh fixing this buffer
should hopefully mean that we can merge
all this good stuff into the dev branch
pretty soon. So we return to nice stable
dev branch once again.
Um, we should be able to start
benchmarking advantage filtering
properly and then we can also start
messing with the other algorithms that
we've been playing with with a bit more
confidence than before because that was
uh an issue, right? We were getting
inconsistent
results. The really major one I'm
looking at at the moment is this uh
variant of diversity is all you need.
The goal is to learn conditioned
policies that are visually
distinguishable. So you can kind of tell
uh you can tell policies, hey, do
different stuff and you'll be able to
see different agents doing different
stuff, playing differently. It's a good
exploration method. It's good for a lot
of stuff. Um I've been working on that.
I've been working on the advantage
filtering stuff. Uh I still have P30. I
have to get back to that. That is the
new advantage
function that I've been working on
because we definitely need to replace
generalized advantage
estimation. And then there are a few
other little miscellaneous things
around. Oh yeah, curriculum learning the
end finding stuff for curriculum
learning. I had to tell Aaron, let me go
link Aaron that real quick.
Okay.
Well, how are folks doing
tonight? I kind of just jumped from one
thing to uh the next all day
since when did I start?
9:30 a little before
maybe 12
hoursish if anyone's looking to get into
RL. Actually, one thing that uh I
usually point folks
to, we do have this blog here. It
doesn't have all the articles. I do like
random sort of out there stuff on X
sometimes mostly AI related but uh the
better ones go here and this quick start
guide in
particular is a really way to get
involved with
RL I give you a few pretty easy to go
through references compared to what's
usually suggested pretty small number of
core papers to read some blog posts that
are easier to digest as well a little
bit of my perspective on how I think
about of research, too. I definitely
suggest
that. I'm sure I'm going to have to keep
updating that as we uh learn more and
more things because we know a lot more
about RL now than even a few months ago
with all the stuff in Puffer.
Tomorrow will
be fix uh the vectorzation for the new
experience buffer. Do
roundroin. Fix our
servers. Make sure the robotics thing
works. Hopefully we get some good
results back on neural
3 and then keep going on the algorithm
stuff.
Okay. Well, I'm going to call it for the
night. So, thanks for tuning in, folks.
We'll be back in the morning. And I'm
pretty much the next like twoish two and
a half weeks, uh, I'm pretty much just
going to be streaming streaming and
debing. kind of gotten my calendar
cleared and uh there's a lot of stuff to
do on puffer. So, we're aiming towards
the next major
release hopefully in the next month or
two. Yep. Star the repo once again.
Really want to see this at 2K. That'd be
great.
But